[Música]
eu costumo dizer que eu tenho a melhor
profissão do mundo imagina viver muitas
vidas viver emprestados e rainhas e
mulher de rua
casar tem muitos filhos não precisa
criar matar o cara o cara levantada
depois é realmente um ano incrível e eu
tenho o privilégio de fazer parte do
pequeno grupo de pessoas
eu não tô falando os artistas
eu tô falando do grupo muito seleto de
pessoas que conseguiram descobrir na
vida é porque não é fácil e ainda
pertenço mais privilegiada ainda porque
eu pertenço há ainda outro grupo ainda
menor que é das pessoas que achavam na
vida que mais gostam de fazer conseguem
pagar suas contas com isso nós isso
virou é quase uma receita de felicidade
é quase tem muito cedo na minha carreira
se eu fui muito bem na profissão e já
com 32 anos por aí eu tinha um relativo
sucesso financeiro comprar uma casa com
piscina e nessa piscina a gente fez uma
reforma na casa na piscina estava
faltando os ladrilhos vizinhos
eu gosto de contar essa história a dor
era pra mim tava faltando os ladrilhos
vinhos e de repente a busca daquele
ladrilho azul da piscina que não era
azul era meio verde também era verde
azul e fim que foi tomada uma
importância ou com amostras e amostras
de ladrilho e uma hora são que eu estava
no colo um monte de madrinha e eu me
caiu uma ficha e eu pensei a mãe artista
está morrendo e
que sempre me deu muito nervoso você
poder chegar uma hora da sua vida assim
já mais velho olhar no espelho e não se
reconhecer num não achar continuidade
daquela sala ué cadê aquela encontrar
mais então aqueles ladrinhos no colo e
eu pensei naquela menina que tinha
entrado para a escola de teatro e eu vi
que ela ainda tabla mas ela precisava
ser ativada
veja bem eu tinha feito trabalho do
bolso e me deram muita alegria que me
deram uma realização é pessoal e até uma
casa com piscina
mas o que parecia perdido
o que parecia que eu precisava fazer que
eu não estava fazendo e eu me dei conta
que fazia muito tempo que não fazia
teatro o teatro que foi sempre a raiz de
tudo pra mim e um rio de atores negros
nós começamos a levar as peças para
decidiu que a gente ia falando nada me
contentava porque não queria só um papel
uma uma boa peça eu tinha sido tocada
pela busca do propósito do que eu estou
fazendo aqui do pará que eu existo só
que ainda não sabia a única coisa que eu
tinha uma satisfação porque não achar a
peça mas aquela aqueles ladrilhos no
colo aquela ficha que tinha caído e
tinha sido uma ficha é muito maior até
que nós lemos a alma boa de sete soando
brest e fazer aquela peça virou mais do
que uma vontade de necessidade
a peça basicamente conta a história de
uma mulher que é mãe que é era muito boa
e não consegue dizer não todos abusam da
boa vontade dela e ela se veste de homem
se faz passar pelo próprio primo pra
conseguir sim ser cruel ser duro impor
limites e aí ela vê o seu negócio
prosperar
brest com essa peça faz a gente pensar
numa coisa que eu sempre acreditei que é
o poder da gentileza porque eu sempre
achei que a gente é muita gente tá mal
sem necessidade
é claro que eu sei que a gente precisa
ser duro muitas vezes para se fazer
respeitar a surtir efeito mas o que eu
sinto
às vezes as pessoas são duras como
primeira lei e não como alternativa à
gentileza que foi abusada
as pessoas são duras com medo e se for
gentil talvez seja abusado e ainda um
completo desperdício da parte melhor das
pessoas a gente vai se tratando muito
mal ea vida vira um inferno
enfim montamos a peça a peça foi um
grande sucesso foram dois anos e meio em
cartaz 220 mil espectadores a gente fez
uma turnê por várias cidades quando a
gente estava no rio sérgio britto um
grande ator saudoso sérgio brito falou
foi que a peça falou pra mim é uma coisa
muito importantes ele foi o dn sabe qual
é o grande segredo do sucesso dessa peça
é tua vontade de dizer esse texto era
verdade eu sentia isso eu sentia que o
quanto está me apropriando das palavras
de um autor para dizer o que eu queria o
quanto que aquilo potenciava
potencializada tudo né eu comecei a
desconfiar da possível gota no oceano
que eu podia ser eu comecei a escolher
as peças que eu queria fazer
segundo a minha necessidade porque havia
tanta coisa pra se dizer através do
teatro tantos autores incríveis que
poderiam fazer as pessoas chegarem
diferentes no escritório na segunda
feira eu via com as pessoas ficavam
arrebatados por aquela questão da peça
e aí eu passei escolher as peças quando
eu lia e sim tinha uma necessidade uma
de propagar aquilo que era muito
importante ser dito que aquilo a valinha
do comic con a minha inquietação pra
dias melhores e isso mudou tudo para mim
eu comecei a acordar com muito mais
vontade de manhã porque eu tinha um
propósito de um propósito que ao mesmo
tempo divertir o espectador
eu punha uma pulga atrás da orelha dele
e as peças foram fazendo muito sucesso
foi muito bem o que me comprovou que é
uma balela essa história de que o
público não quer dar
pensando os maiores seres da raça humana
e quando isso é feito então através do
humor
aí tem uma potência incrível eu acredito
do amor como um grande aliado da
reflexão por isso que eu amo o brest
o brest fala divertir pra comunicar nas
peças dele ele conta histórias ótimas
divertidas
ele quer ele acha que o teatro precisa
ser divertido mas ele faz você sempre p
ver que a história da humanidade foi
feita pelos humanos pelos homens
e ele te convida a pôr a mão na massa da
história ativar o seu agente
transformador e de alguma maneira eu
acho que foi o que aconteceu comigo eu
acho que eu resolvi pôr a mão na massa
da minha história pra minimamente eja
pôr a mão na massa da história e watch v
o meu agente transformador esse agente
transformador que muita gente muitas
vezes a gente deixa trabalhar só para
quem paga o nosso salário a gente pode
até fazer coisas ótimas onde paga o
nosso salário e também de realizações
pessoais isso seria o ideal mas a gente
eu sinto que a gente abandona muitos
projetos pessoais em nome do ganha-pão
muito dos nossos ideais e da nossa
felicidade como se felicidade não
precisa também de trabalho e
criatividade
enfim é hoje eu sinto que a minha grande
função como atriz é polir palavras como
se eu pegar essas palavras que estão lá
empoeiradas restante dessa um trato nela
declare a se elas e colocasse elas pra
viver no peito do espectador como se eu
dissesse olho que eu li olho como que
esse cara escreveu há 100 anos atrás faz
sentido para você hoje e da voz proto
angústia nem sabe aquilo que que você
sente não consegue dizer o teatro às
vezes pode dizer por você e aí foram
várias peças
é curioso como é muitas das peças que a
gente fez
tem como é tema essa questão que foi a
minha questão inicial de como que a luta
pelo ganha pão pode afastar você do meu
ideal
o galileu do brest que a gente também
fez hélio foi aquele que cedeu né ele
conseguia provar que a terra girava em
torno do sol e ele teve que negar isso
pra não ser jogado na fogueira da santa
inquisição e eu sinto que de uma guerra
maneira somos todos brasileiros é
negando óbvio diariamente a enfrentar
nossas inúmeras fogueiras
nessa estrutura que a gente evento e ver
essa sociedade pautada pelo que rende às
estruturas de poder no mundo corporativo
esses chefes vaidosa a gente vai vendo
um monte de projetos ótimos que podiam
fazer muito melhor para a humanidade
sendo engavetados dando lugar aqueles
projetos que são só rentáveis nem a
gente vai fazendo cara de paisagem
próprio surdo tudo em nome do leite das
crianças é difícil mesmo mas na mesma
história do galileu tenha uma questão
que que se inquieta que é a brecha
porque o galileu ele foi posto em prisão
domiciliar
assim que ele e negou e foi na prisão
domiciliar vigiada pela inquisição que
escreveu a sua obra máxima ue diz costa
só que a lu velho quase cego vigiado
ele escreveu duas cópias de cada um
proibidão e ele esconde essa cópia
escondida
ele conseguiu levar o que levar sempre a
holanda hoje publicado longe dos olhos
da inquisição e é muito do que chegou
dos seus ensinamentos pra gente ele eu
acho abr essa né
galileu a sua peça pra mesmo comprimido
por uma atitude uma estrutura de poder
continuar a ser galileu eu sempre me
pergunto que brechas que a gente pode
achar dentro dessa estrutura estrutura
que a gente evento viver onde o que vale
é o que rende pra estar minimamente em
dia com os nossos ideais porque nos
vender todos vamos não tem jeito a gente
tem contas a pagar e fazer concessões
faz parte mas até onde essa que eu sinto
que é a grande questão o até hoje porque
eu sinto que você pode perder ou ganhar
eu sinto que você precisa ficar atento
se você deixar só a vida te levar e
aceitando as propostas de sucesso que a
vida pode oferecer você tem o risco de
fracassar na tua felicidade ea
felicidade em ganhar dinheiro é muito
bom mas a prata e felicidade às vezes
você tem que estar disposto a não ganhar
sempre mas para não ganhar sempre você
tem que dizer não ao dinheiro e para ter
essa liberdade você precisa ter um pouco
de dinheiro que é o que eu chamo do
dinheiro do não eu falo sempre os meus
amigos tenham o dinheiro do não porque o
centro de hoje uma das coisas mais
é revolucionário que você pode fazer é
tentar viver com menos para que você
possa lutar pelos caminhos que podem se
conectar a tua felicidade mas não é
fácil não é fácil tem que ficar atento e
tem que fazer força para nadar contra a
corrente porque a gente vive uma
epidemia avassaladora eu sinto uma vida
que ficou muito veloz que nos arrasta
todos nós lá escravos agora do nosso
na o tecnológico com um problema na
cervical com o nariz enfiado nas telas
trabalhando 30 horas por dia senão para
quem paga o nosso salário pra gente
mesmo pra nossa existência na rede
aaaah vida postadas a biografia e
precisa ser postada que vamos combinar
um trabalho infernal ea vida virou essa
loucura
e dá-lhe remédio nem eu nem outro dia eu
estava indo almoçar no restaurante
natural que fica perto da minha casa que
eu sempre achei que lá no restaurante
natural tem virado na farmácia
achei que um sintoma tão claro dos
nossos tempos restaurante natural ir a
uma farmácia
parece um prédio que desistiu então eu
acho que a gente tem que ficar atento
porque a vida arrasta eu agradeço
àqueles ladrinhos o meu colo de certa
maneira por terem naquela hora me dado
alguma consciência do perigo
agora tá faltando os ladrilhos lá na
minha piscina eu preciso repor o pedido
também mas acho que vou deixar eles lá
pra ele sempre me lembrarem de nadar
contra a corrente
vamos brigar
[Aplausos]